o la manera clonar qué tal es una
lección muy importante de eeuu porque si
bien no va a tener un impacto concreto
en la política de mianmar si va a ser
que sus aliados paguen un costo político
mucho más fuerte por apoyarnos
particularmente estamos hablando de los
países de la zona del sureste asiático
integrados en el asean una cosa es
apoyar un país que está en una denuncia
en un juicio o que la prensa acusa y
otra otra cosa es ser aliado de un país
o hacer silencio frente a un vecino que
es a este curso de genocidio y las
gracias unidos y cuál es la situación de
los más de 700 mil musulmanes rojilla
que han huido de mianmar y de estar en
campos de refugiados en bangladesh
porque la importancia de retomar la
crisis hoy
bueno para retomar la importancia de
crisis porque eeuu ha aumentado su
presencia política y le da mayor
importancia a la región del mismo
secretario todo blinken ha estado en
malasia en la indolencia países
musulmanes recordemos que las provincias
son son musulmanes también en un país de
mayoría budista esto es muy importante y
es efectivamente la situación de la
gente en esta de las noticias que están
en manda es es pésima en es pésima están
sometidos a todo tipo de falta de comida
falta de medicinas de violencia
incendios nuevas climáticos es un
problema también humanitario que está
muy bien que las naciones unidas se
involucran directamente y para poner el
contexto a nuestros televidentes por
favor recuerde nos la raíz de esta
persecución persecución contra la etnia
musulmana de mi amor
como te decía es un país mayoría budista
esto lo dice él siempre ha estado hoy
tiene la reflexión de los militares
contra todas las minorías e incluso las
minorías que se
sienten políticamente pero de vaquillas
proviene se hace bastante tiempo porque
el ejército de miramar no nos reconoce
como una etnia del país y se ha dedicado
sistemáticamente a perseguirlos y
expulsarlos y todavía hay rojilla en
mianmar y cuál es su situación en medio
de la junta militar que gobierna el país
todavía hay hay población línea y
efectivamente viven hoy la misma
situación de represión de violencia que
el resto de minorías recordemos que la
junta militar está bombardeando
poblaciones civiles no sólo agencias
sino de otro tipo de minorías incluso a
budistas todo aquel que está en contra
de las fundamentales está sufren una
represión salvaje desde el golpe del
primero de febrero del año pasado